hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
lektion 17 hört zu und spricht nach
guten tag was möchten sie bestellen
ich nehme einen fruchtsalat bitte ich
nehme einen fruchtsalat bitte möchten
sie dazu noch etwas trinken möchten sie
dazu noch etwas trinken
ja ich trinke ein wasser mit kohlensäure
bitte ja ich trinke ein wasser mit
kohlensäure bitten und sie was nehmen
sie und sie was nehmen sie
ich trinke einen kaffee ohne milch ich
trinke einen kaffee ohne milch
und dazu esse ich einen kuchen und dazu
esse ich einen kuchen
können wir bezahlen bitte können wir
bezahlen bitte
ja gern bezahlen sie zusammen oder
getrennt
getrennt getrennt bitte
wer bezahlt was ich bezahle das stück
pizza die portion pommes die tasse
kaffee und die dose cola
ich bezahle das stück pizza die portion
pommes die tasse kaffee und die dose
cola und ich bezahle den teller pasta
den becher eis das glas orangensaft und
die flasche so da und ich bezahle den
teller pasta den becher eis das glas
orangensaft und die flasche so der
entschuldigung ich habe ein problem
entschuldigung ich habe ein problem ja
wie kann ich ihnen helfen ja wie kann
ich ihnen helfen
schauen sie mal mein puls ist nicht
richtig durchgebraten es ist noch rot
das ist gefährlich schauen sie mal mein
puls ist nicht richtig durchgebraten es
ist noch wo das ist gefährlich oh ja es
ist noch rosa was tut mir leid ich
bringe das gleich in die küche damit sie
es nochmals beraten
oh ja es ist noch rosa das tut mir leid
ich bringe das gleich in die küche
damit sie es nochmals braten
wie schmeckt ihnen das essen nicht gut
gar nicht der gute die teigwaren sind
die viel zu weiche sie sind vermochte
die drei geworden sind die viel zu
weiche sie sind verkochte was da muss
man all dente kochen mamma mia
hallo entschuldigung
hallo
ja
ich habe ein kaltes bier bestellt aber
das hier ist warm
ich kann kein warmes bier trinken ich
habe ein kaltes bier bestellt aber das
hier ist warm
ich kann kein warmes bier trinken
entschuldigen sie ich bringe ihnen ein
neues entschuldigen sie ich bringe ihnen
ein neues den kaffee kann ich nicht
trinken
der ist viel zu schwach den kaffee kann
ich nicht trinken
der ist viel zu schwach bringen sie mir
bitte einen starken kaffee nicht so eine
bessere brühe bringen sie mir bitte
einen starken kaffee nicht zwar eine
bessere gebrüder entschuldigung bringen
sie mir bitte salz und pfeffer bringen
sie mir bitte salz und pfeffer die suppe
ist wir zu fahrig muss sie nach würzen
die suppe ist wir zu fahrig muss sie
nach würzen
er stellt das gemüse er stellt das
gemüse er schneidet das gemüse er
schneidet das gemüse er rührt mit dem
mixer den teig gerührt mit dem mixer den
teig
er rollt den teig ausgerollt den teig
aus er belegt die pizza er belegt die
pizza er backt die pizza er backt die
pizza er dreht das essen an
er dreht das essen an
er kocht eine suppe er kocht eine suppe
er probiert die suppe er probiert die
suppe
ich mag gemüse ich mag gemüse ich esse
gern gemüse ich esse
gemüse ich mag wein
ich mag wein
ich trinke gern wein
ich trinke nicht gern cola
ich esse nicht gern schokolade
noch weiß wir brauchen noch reis kaufst
du bitte auch noch milch kaufst du bitte
auch noch milch wir haben keinen
knoblauch mehr
wir haben keinen knoblauch mehr
können sie mir helfen können sie mir
helfen wo ist hier die kasse wo ist hier
die kasse gehen sie geradeaus und dann
nach links gehen sie geradeaus und dann
nach links
gehen sie
nach rechts und dann geradeaus gehen sie
nach rechts und dann geradeaus die
zitrone ist sauer
die zitrone ist sauer
anna ist süß die banane ist süß der
pfeffer ist scharf der pfeffer ist
scharf der kaffee ist bitter der kaffee
ist bitter ich esse nie fleisch
ich esse
nie fleisch ich bin vegetarier
ich bin vegetarier
ich kaufe immer brot und milch ein
gemüse und früchte sind gesund
[Musik]
man soll gemüse und früchte essen
man soll gemüse und früchte essen zucker
und fett sind ungesund
fällt sind ungesund man soll wenig
zucker und fett konsumieren
man soll wenig zucker und fett
konsumieren